Hey,
what's going on is bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday, uh,
January 25th, 2060. What's going on out?
How are Ya? Ah, you know how I'm
doing when I'm not doing good?
Uh, everybody in Denver settling in
with a big fucking smile on your face,
aren't ya?
Ah,
you fucking pot smoking
[inaudible] with the goddamn him.
Ponchos um,
congratulations to the Broncos.
They deserved it right out of the
gate. You know, we took the ball,
they stopped us. And I remember when they
scored in the first drive, I was like,
that was disturbingly easy.
Um,
and uh, you know, they just, we have,
they just von Fucking
Miller. I mean, if the,
if he was in the backfield
any quicker during the game,
he be taken the fucking
snap. I mean, it was brutal.
We just didn't have any answers
on the outfit, the blood. And, uh,
that's what did it,
not the fucking field goal and not
us going forward on fourth down.
I can only imagine what they're saying.
I'm, I'm doing this Sunday night.
I can imagine the sports talk radio that
they're second guessing bill Belichick.
Yeah. Second guessing. Yes. Second guess
him. It's just bill Bellacheck. Oh,
what do you, yeah, you're the other
fucking, you've never coached on any
can level three work? No water. You
to kick the field goal during winter
toward show Perry.
I love all people think like,
like something earlier in the game.
If they just did this, that, that,
that doesn't change everything after that.
I mean how many fucking
back to the futures do they
have to make that you see if
you change one thing that it
changes everything else self.
If the Patriots did kick the fucking thing
and we got to within five and when we
got the ball back,
the fact that a touchdown would put us
ahead rather than us being down by eight,
they would have had a completely
different fucking defense. Okay.
Before they fucking do all
of that second guessing shit,
you know fucking Versie was, was going
through that too. I said, I was saying,
I was saying when they did it was dumb.
Oh did you non coach Versie Aminah
listen to you as opposed to to to fucking
Bella check. Um, when they did
it, I was like, I love the,
I love the call going forward.
We weren't able to move the fucking ball
at all on offense the entire fucking
game.
We will,
the only reason why we had a touchdown
was because they had that fucking lateral.
And even then, then we missed a fucking
extra point. It just, it wasn't our day.
Even when we had got a gift,
we fucked it up and then we gave it right
back with a pick and then they score
it. But um, yeah,
we weren't able to move the fucking
ball be Tom Brady went back,
there was somebody in his face,
you know,
chomping at the fucking is his legs as
he was trying to throw the fucking thing.
You're that close. I, I, I agreed with
going forward. It didn't work out,
but you know how life is sometimes. So,
um, but it was a great season and, um,
for what they accomplished with all
the injuries and all that type of shit,
it was amazing. And I got
to tell you, I am, um,
I'm definitely rooting
for a Peyton manning.
I'd like to see him go out like John
Elway would be pretty cool for another guy
in the Broncos does that. But uh, then he
also, he got to love Cam Newton. You know,
Jesus Christ,
you don't think I don't like about Cam.
Newton is one more person tells me
there's nobody having more fun than him.
It's like a kid on Christmas Day.
He's like a,
he's like a kid when his second
birthday, it's like, I get it.
He's having fun.
He's also totally fucking hamming it up
and making sure his next sneaker deal
would be, it will be even 10 times what
the fuck he has right now. Let's not just,
let's start,
be totally naive here or just act like
everything he's doing is just because he
loves playing the game.
But he wasn't this fucking animated
what he was at a a fucking Auburn.
I used to watch shows, games, root
against, hi. I used to word against him,
so I would watch and I was, he, he wasn't
doing all that shit. But then again,
he couldn't get paid or at least legally
he couldn't get paid back then. So,
you know, what was the point? A
dance it every time you fuck it.
I love when that one guy fucking a,
they,
they through the screen pass and he ran
all the way to the other side of the
field.
By the time he gets there,
Cam Newton runs in with them and
kind of fucking jumps in on that guy.
Superbowl Superbowl,
his touchdown salivate celebration.
And then the camera man is just following
Cam Newton for the rest of the time.
And um,
in my, uh, in my business, that's a,
that's called a [inaudible], not stealing
is seen. It's called uh, AH, Jesus Christ.
I don't do enough acting to,
even though steel,
the xen is when you're better than
the other person. Upstaging somebody.
He was upstaging him. So, um,
I just don't need anybody else telling
me how much fun Cam Newton's having.
I get it.
He's having a good time,
but he's also completely hamming
it up because when he does,
he makes a zillion dollars. However, as
crushing as the Patriots lost was like,
I literally had to,
I had to go for a walk after they
lost. Um, and I gotta tell you,
I felt like we were
going to lose that game.
Yeah.
You know, sometime in the second quarter,
I was just like, this, I can feel it.
This just isn't our day. It
just wasn't Brady never, I mean,
they were all over him. He
never got comfortable and, uh,
it wasn't screaming and yelling and
getting people going. I thought,
but I fucking defense played great.
Um, but I, Gee, I don't know.
I just sometimes you can just feel,
it's just not your fucking day.
So I literally had to go for a walk,
went to the bank,
I mailed something, I got the
car washed. It was like nobody,
there was like a ghost town.
It was just like, you know,
some fucking nerds or whatever who
don't give a shit about and some poor
bastards who had to work. And, um, yeah,
I went to the car wash and
then I went to this, uh, uh,
Mediterranean, Middle East, and whenever
the fuck it has got one of those raps,
the Shawarma wraps, whatever the fuck
you call it. And it actually worked out.
Perfect. Guy Walked a few blocks
over. I got the rap, I ate it,
I watched some of the Carolina Arizona
game. And then when I came back,
right as I came back, the
guy was finishing my car
and he put his hand up like,
Oh, whose car resists? It was
fucking perfect, perfect timing. Um,
that was about the only a good thing
that happened during those three hours of
watching the fucking game.
But um,
okay.
Anyways, I got to tell
you is as bad as, um,
as bad as the, the feeling I
had when the Patriots lost. Um,
the one thing that cheered
me up was watching that
Carolina fans fall out of the
fucking stance.
That was one of the funniest fucking
things I've seen in a long time.
He just completely, he missed time when
the player was coming down. I think he,
I think he just ran down and he just,
Mitch Ms Judge with the rail was and he
just slammed into it and just went right
up and over, straight up
and over. I mean if you,
if you put a coat rack on wheels, it would
have landed lighter than this guy did.
There was just nothing athletic,
a bottom. It was just all fucking,
it was at a nourisher of set the
proper physics. Jeremy just read that.
I just wish I could have heard his
thoughts when he was at the tipping point
when his legs were right up.
But pointing at the 12 and his head was
at six o'clock right as it started to
come around till about 1145
you know,
he was lying to himself hanging onto the
rail. Like, I got this, I got this. Ah,
fuck,
Oh,
this is stupid dad jeans just shooting
up in the air right from the gap.
It just fucking lands on the ground.
I liked when he got up to,
and then he tried to like climb back up
in the stands and that dude was there.
Like I know, buddy. What, why
don't you just walk around?
We don't need your fallen down again.
Um,
okay.
I'll tell you what the funny thing is
is you know there's going to be some
lawyer scare in the fuck out
of the owner of that team.
Then emotionless maniac that they kept
cutting too when he would just be sitting
there like he was listening to the
verdict of his own murder trial. Um,
the fuck is what that guy is. He
just focused on the super bowl.
Everybody in his luxury box is going nuts.
He's got his fucking furred up a wife.
That's when you know you got money when
your wife has a fur coat and hasn't been
spray painted. You know,
that's when you know that it's,
you guys are living a level of wealth
that you don't even run into commoners to
you.
You know,
there's always some contents got to come
along and fucking spray paint somebody
fur coat,
which I've never understood.
It's like the animal died and now
he's just going to throw out a tidy,
at least there was a jacket.
You know what I mean?
Like if somebody came and killed me,
it made a jacket out of me.
I wouldn't want you to spray paint it,
you know,
and then they're just going to throw it
out. Then I'm just like a fucking jacket,
you know, in a landfill.
Right. Floating in the ocean.
Let the bitch walk around with it.
Um, anyways. Jesus fucking
Christ. Oh diary. Right now.
Nobody's having more fun in
the national football league.
Oh God. I was watching the
game with a buddy of mine.
We were just throwing out the cliches
all day. He gets, he gets here.
He's the first one here. When
he's the last one to leave.
I'll tell you right now,
you can be 22 guys like dad. I
could coach. His date goes to both.
Okay
Day. Right now you have to know
where you are on the field.
Why would you run a five yard route when
you need six yards for a first down?
I mean,
that just doesn't make any sense.
I'll tell you out there. They are
just, they're just having fun up there.
They're just having fun. That's what this
game's all about. The owner out there,
they are loose. He's just
out there slinging it. Um,
anyways, and just like that. My
fucking football season is over.
So who do you like in the Superbowl?
I'll tell you what I don't like.
Have you seen that fucking
advertisement for Super Bowl 50,
the 50s and gold and for whatever
reason, this woman standing? Yeah. Yeah.
Looking like the hot chick that walks
in and some gum shoe movie from the
fucking 1940s.
She stayed in there on a rank,
Colton high heels with
like a golden umbrella
telling you it's,
it's over.
It's fucking over. The bills hired a, uh,
I don't know what they are.
They had a woman for some job or,
but it's fucking over
it. It's done. It's done.
Those three hours where you
could get away as a married guy,
you could just get away for three
hours. It's, it's, it's over. It's, I,
it's going to sound like
the Westminster dog show
about seven years. You
know, we had a great run,
we had a great run and
now it's over, you know,
but it's our own damn fault. It's our
own damn fault. You know what it was,
we just couldn't hide the joy we were
having watching football without them.
We couldn't hide the joy. And there's
nothing that a noise of fucking woman,
like a bunch of guys going and having a
good time without them. So they're red.
That dressing in pink for a fucking month,
it's, it's fucking, it's fucking over.
Uh,
I wish I just knew. I just knew, I wish
I knew that it was going to come to this.
I would have tried to enjoy,
you know,
my first 37, 38 years of
football, they just flew by.
I would have tried to enjoy them a
little bit more and now it's over.
Okay,
we should make a trade. We says what we
should do, we should just trade them.
The wn VA just go like,
well,
what if we just give you
a league that we started?
It'd be almost like a divorce where you
just get it even though you didn't do
anything.
Or maybe you'd like emotionally supported
the guy or some shit or whatever the
fuck you say at the court. Right?
You just give them the w NBA.
You can be the commissioners,
all the owners, the commentators,
the RAF's you can be,
everybody in the stands will give you
your section of Buffalo wild wings.
You know, just, just don't take
NFL football from his kidney,
kidney. Just not just can you give
us, can you just leave us with that?
Can we just have that?
Ah,
God,
maybe I'm just too old to understand it.
Coach, can you tell us what
happened there in the first half?
Well,
we weren't getting it done.
I just don't know if I'm ready for that,
you know?
I Dunno
that just yet. I don't, I don't
know where, where do you go now?
Yeah.
I guess it gets you only
place left is you, you,
you become one of those weird old guys
that plays chess and the [inaudible]
park
is about chess.
It's boring and quiet enough that they
don't notice that you're over there
without them enjoying yourself.
You know?
That's the genius. You ever see a guy
who's been married for like 50 years?
Like the genius of him, I swear to God,
the genius of them is they fucking,
they know how to have a good time
without their wife notices it.
So it doesn't Pique our interest.
Right. She's fucking over in the choir.
She didn't give a shit. Right.
But young guys were idiots.
We come home with a big grin on her face
talking about how awesome it was, blah,
blah.
And all they hear is this motherfucker
had the nerve to go out for three hours
and not miss me and not think about me.
Well,
we'll see about that,
won't we?
Okay.
Um,
it's fucking over.
Ah, it's over. Just like the
Patriots season. So who do
you guys like in the, um,
who do you guys like in the,
uh,
yeah,
I'm trying to think of an
activity that women do.
We're fucking group that they have
that I would like to infiltrate. And I,
for the life of me, I can't
think of it. You know,
what are they got off
the f the forage club.
Okay.
Girl Scouting.
MMM.
Any those feminists groups,
there'd be a funny thing to join.
Join one of those fucking groups
and act like you're a feminist.
He just go down there and you
say like the most ignorant,
but like yet it's still pro women shit
come down there with a fucking bud tall.
Yeah. I just wanted to say, you know, I
came down here to support your broads.
You know, I think it's a, I think it's
fucked up the way that God treats you.
You know,
just cause you run around with a skirt
and it takes you long to get ready.
Doesn't mean you can't run the company.
Right. My right ladies. Come on bill.
We really appreciate you coming down here.
We think what you're saying is positive.
We just see some buzzwords here that we,
uh, put into a spreadsheet,
a little pamphlet thing that
we'd like you to look at.
Maybe you could not say them the next
meeting. Maybe take a couple of weeks off.
Oh no damn.
Showed up every week.
Yeah.
Wait for him to kick me out.
Then I sue him for being sexist.
Um, I'm just a grumpy old
man. That's all it is.
I am a grumpy old man who
wants things to stay the same.
Okay.
You know, do I make any money off the
NFL? I don't. I do have the mute button.
You gotta you gotta love the mute button.
Anytime they cut to the chick on the
sideline. I just fucking, I hit mute,
you know, just trying to,
to keep it going, you know,
just for another couple more weeks.
How come we can't blah,
blah blah and the, okay. All right. Jesus
Christ. I think it really comes up, huh?
What are you going to do? It's
a, you know, it's fucking over.
It's our own goddamn faults. We just
had too much fucking fun without them.
So, you know, the next thing
we start, just, you come home,
you get, you get the tone it
down. Fucking tone it down.
Anyways, let's just plow ahead
here. So I still live in, even said,
what is it, the, uh, super bowl. Who
Do you like? Panthers of Broncos?
You know, I was impressed
at the panthers. Fucking,
we're kicking the shit out of Arizona
and they didn't take the foot off the gas
pedal this week. Um, I don't know,
but the Broncos have that fucking defense.
But our offensive line stakes,
it doesn't stink. We just banged up. So I
don't know. I don't know how good the, uh,
I dunno. I know. You know what?
I don't even fucking know.
I'm still so fucking annoyed
by the Goddamn the finality.
I'm not even that we'd lost cause I
felt Denver was a better fucking team.
God Damn mother fucker. All right.
That's it. Plowing ahead. Oh,
by the way, did I mention I saw a, the
hateful late. Did anybody see that?
Did anybody see the hateful eight?
I can't remember if I talked about it.
I saw it in 70 millimeter at
the arclight here and, uh,
in Los Angeles,
um,
it had an intermission and it
had an overture in the beginning.
There were no coming attractions
cause who the fuck's gonna shoot that?
The 70 millimeter.
Right.
And I absolutely fucking love
that movie from start to finish.
I love the pacing of it. I
loved the whole, I just loved,
I loved it. I just, the whole fun.
It was just an experience.
Like Tarantino was like,
I don't give a fuck about your
cell phone. How you, your,
your fucking brain is all scrambled now
cause you're looking at an iPad screen.
All God Damn Day Long.
I don't give a fuck the movies this long.
This is the movie I wanted to make.
And you can settle the fucking or leave.
Is it just an experience? I absolutely
fucking love that movie. Um, Oh,
speaking of with speaking of iPads,
so you see when the Patriots I pads went,
oh no, stranger to the Broncos
go out. But that weird,
that's just one of those strange things.
Just one of those fluke things that
happen to happen and die. It's all good.
It's all good because it happened to the
Patriots now had it happened the other
way around and it was in our stadium.
Oh Jesus.
How many months would ESPN
talk about that? You know,
versus he called me today
instead of former quarterback,
I think it was for the giants. Don't
even know it was saying like, yeah,
we just take air out of the
ball all the fucking time.
Everybody did it and everybody does it.
Okay.
Once again, and I know you
guys are like, oh Jesus, Bill,
how long are you going to harp on this
while they talked about it for fucking
eight months. You know,
I think since, you know,
the judge threw it out of court, I mean
it hasn't been eight months since then,
has it? September, October,
November, December, January.
You got another three months of this shit.
Um,
anyways, enough of that shit. I, uh,
all by the way, I started that, that um,
that series top boy,
top boy on a Netflix and
a fucking great show,
two episodes in enjoying it,
but Jesus Christ,
you got to put on the fucking subtitles.
Good Lord.
Mumbling fast as fuck.
It's almost as bad as peaky blinders,
but peaky blinders.
You can understand the shit was supposed
to happen like a hundred years ago.
This shit here,
as far as I can tell,
supposed to be going on right now
and I still can't understand them.
I don't think they say in it enough.
Um, stamps.com everybody here,
we got a little advertising for this week.
stamps.com.
You know there's gotta be a
better way to mail and ship stuff.
Go to the post office,
takes up so much time.
A leasing a postage meter
is way too expensive. Turns
out there is a better way.
stamps.com with stamps.com you can buy
and print official US postage for any
okay
or package right from your
desk using your own cup
and even
gets stressful postage discount.
She can't find it.
The post office plus stamps.com is
more powerful than a postage at just a
fraction of the cost.
You can save at least 50% compared to a
postage meter and you avoid all the time
consuming trips to the post office.
I use stamps.com anytime I
send my posters out right now,
you can sign up for stamps.com and use
my last name bur for this special offer,
four week trial plus a $110 bonus offer
including postage and a digital stale
scale. Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top,
the homepage and type in burr that
stamps.com enter burr. Ah, right.
And v m t watches movement watches
was started by two college dropouts.
Man,
with the idea to make quality watches
that don't break your bank starting at
just 95 bucks and sold online. They
cut out all the bullshit retail markup.
Um, they sent me some watches.
He sings a fucking, all right.
Quality materials and sleek designs, their
PR, the perfect everyday watch. It's,
you know, if you get mugged, you
don't give a fuck right? Here you go.
Take the God damn thing. I'll buy another
one before you get it home. Uh, easy.
It's easy.
Order online today for free shipping.
Free returns in a 24 month warranty.
Join the movement and say no to big brand
retail markups and saying yes to great
style.
Checkout MVMT watches.com/burr and
you'll get 15% off your entire purchase.
That's MVMT, watches.com/burr. And lastly,
but not leastly blue apron,
everybody.
All right. Listen, you don't
need to know how to cook,
but you need to know how to cook it right?
If you want to start nailing the
top fucking chicks out there, right?
I'm kidding. All right. Now
it helps. Anything helps.
Especially when you look like me, you
know it's healthy. You can whip up a dish,
you know, grab a couple of wine glasses,
act like you know what you're doing.
You know, be like, oh, I don't want to
go to the fucking supermarket. Well,
that's what blue apron comes in.
All right?
Not only do you get to feel like you
know your way around the kitchen,
but cooking your home means eating
healthier and saving money instead of
ordering expensive takeout again,
but where do you start?
Blue a pronoun she covered
for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers all the fresh
ingredients you need to create home cooked
meals. Just follow the easy
step by step instructions.
Each meal can be prepared
in 40 minutes or less.
No overwhelming trips to the
grocery store. No more sad takeout.
No matter your dietary preferences.
Blue Apron makes it a breeze to discover
and prepare dishes like chicken and
sage biscuit,
pot pie,
shrimp and Pineapple Fried Rice,
Philly style Hoagie with green peppers,
onions,
mushrooms and aged cheddar sauce.
Okay.
Chicken scab, Fellini, whatever the
fuck this is with rob. We get it.
Lemon butter shrimp. What am I gonna
read the whole menu. All right, I got it.
There's a bunch of shit on here.
Tomato quiche with a simple green salad,
right in your own kitchen.
Not In the bathroom.
They may get in the kitchen and recipes
of between 500 700 calories. Proportion,
delicious and good for you right now.
You can get your first two meals
for free@blueapron.com slash bird.
That's blue apron.com/burr blue apron.
A better way to cook.
Um,
okay.
All right, here we go.
You know, be cool though.
If there was like a female
like Vince Lombardi who came
and you know what I mean?
And she had the exact same like,
like demeanor,
nobody tablet
out there. Okay, what the Hell is going
today?
Thanks.
Hey everybody,
grab a towel.
Let's,
let's focus on next week.
Um, oh, by the way, uh, I want to thank,
uh,
Brian Tissue for letting me be a part of
the Bonzo bash this past Friday night.
Uh, I got to go down there
and cohosted with him and, uh,
just the amount of drummers that I saw
that night and I got to stand behind them.
Does any youtube video you're going to
see my dumb fucking head just staring at
their base drum foot.
Um,
these are some of the guys that played
last Friday night. Stephen Parkins,
Jane's Addiction.
Chad Smith from the Chili peppers.
Dave Lombardo from dead
cross and a slayer.
Uh, who else? I'm going from memory.
Um, oh, there's a kind of, uh,
Greg Potter from the buddy rich band
guide plays in a buddy rich band and
crushed a Zeppelin song that's pretty
much running the gamut. Simon. Right.
Last time I saw Simon Right, play a
song on the who made who tour? Uh,
Robert [inaudible] from skid row. Last
time I saw him, they opened for Aerosmith,
New Year's Eve, 1989.
December 31st at the Boston,
uh,
will Calhoun was there.
Brad Whitford from Arrowsmith
Carmen, uh, App Asi.
Oh my God. Ray Lazear from corn
absolutely destroyed Achilles last stand.
Scott, John Humble. I never heard
of fucking destroyed cashmere.
Just so many fucking amazing drummers
and I actually got to sit in,
which is fucking hilarious. I got to
sit in inbetween guys at that level. Uh,
I played that song off of, uh, the
presence album for your love and uh,
I'm sorry for your love
for your life and uh,
I want to thank everyone in the Moby
Dick's for helping walk me through that
song. Um, uh, you know,
you know what it was,
I fucked up a lot during the song,
but I nailed the arrangement
as far as like all the changes.
I was on it for that.
And I find that if you do that,
that people in the crowd don't notice
that you're fucking up the fills.
There was like one big Phil and I
fucking ripped out on the thing.
I was so fucking pissed. Um, what
are you gonna do it? But it was, uh,
it was just a fucking amazing night and
four hours fucking long watching these
guys.
And they had this bond,
them fucking vista lights set the
exact same style kit that he had.
Um, if you watch the song and the
song remains the same and this,
the fucking kicked Rome was wide open.
They had nothing in there.
They didn't even have felt
strip going across it.
It was one of the sickest sounds I've
ever heard in my life. Big 26 inch kit.
They had the two tympanies to the left
of the high hat and then the fucking
Gong. And it's, I'm so pissed at the end
of the song, I didn't hit the fucking Gog,
how many fucking opportunities to get
to do that and I blew it. But, um,
I just said I just had the
best time doing it. And, uh,
then of course I'm driving home. It was
down in Anaheim and I'm driving home.
And the best thing about driving home at
night in La is just finally no traffic.
And I'm fucking cruising. And, uh,
all of a sudden the fucking five just
comes to a grinding halt in three,
four lanes,
merge down to one and then are
forced off of the highway into like a
neighborhood.
Uh,
because the only time they obviously that
they can fix the highways is at night.
So I have empathy for these
state workers out here,
but um, sucked for me
and I just, I completely,
I had like a fucking meltdown for about
five minutes and I was texting everyone
that I got a number from that was on
the show telling them not to get on the
five and a fuck Bruton.
And once again,
I just don't understand why
people buy fast cars out here.
Unless you have a pickup truck with
a trailer and you can drive that car,
you can tow the car to a race track.
I just don't understand. You know,
these fucking cars you see out here,
they can go like 180 hundred
60 tour to miles an hour.
Some of these fucking cars. It's
like, where are you doing that?
I Dunno.
It's fucking ridiculous. I beeped at this
lady today. That was probably a dick.
I just really, I can't fucking
stand people when they sit
at a Goddamn red light.
You're right behind them.
And then when the light turns green,
they put on their fucking left
turn signal and then you beat bad.
And they're like, what the fuck?
It's like, give me a heads up.
Give me a heads up so I could have
backed off and gone around you,
your fucking Dick. Now the 20
people behind me are going to go by.
I'm going to miss the fucking light. Now
I'm on your schedule. You know, like that.
That's never happened to you. You'd
never been the person behind that person.
You don't fucking remember. Now your
first align, you just say fuck it.
Sorry. Most of this shit, everything
that I'm saying, women in the NFL,
all of this shit,
most of the shit has nothing to do with.
It has to do with the fact
that my team lost, you know,
so now I'm just fucking
grumpy. Um, anyways,
today.
Okay.
Kipper um, all right. Oh, hey,
I'm going to be playing out live again. If
you guys, uh, Andrew would stand up. Oh,
Dean del Rey.
Dean del Rey's a 50th birthday.
You got to come down to this at the
El Rey theater, Delray at the El Rey.
Uh,
it's going to be an unbelievable fucking
lineup of comedians and musicians to
celebrate. Dean Del Rey's
50th. And of course,
my fucking Internet cuts out. I finally
had the fucking thing finally had it.
I had it all fucking lined up.
I was ready to read off the whole thing.
And what happens?
It just fucking disappears.
You fucking cunt. All right,
well this is what I know.
MMM.
Joe Rogan is going to be doing some
stand up there. Uh, I will be on it.
Chris Delea me get to the flyer here.
Let me get to the fly. Uh, there it is.
There's the flyer. All right.
Brian Red Band, Joe Bart,
Nick Rosebell
tailgate legend Joe Bart,
Nick Dean del. Ray's going
to be there. And, uh,
after we do a bunch of stand up,
uh, we're going to do some, uh,
from what I heard,
there's going to be all these musicians
there and they're going to play the
entire highway to hell album.
Uh,
Rudy SARS hoes going to be
there from a Ozzy Osborne.
Uh, Dave Cushner from velvet revolver. Ed,
the Gao does the music for F
is for family. Dave Lombardo,
Tracie guns, Gilby clack from guns and
roses. It's going to be fucking say,
it's going to be a bus going to be a lot
of fun. Um, so come on down February 2nd.
You can get tickets@agoldenvoice.com.
MMM.
All right. Let's, uh, let's continue on
here with, with the, uh, with the podcast.
What else did I want to talk about?
Is there anything, anything at all?
It's like if I,
as I settle into the fact
that might fucking football season
is over, um, oh, Jesus Christ,
the Patrice O'Neal benefit. How the
fuck did I almost forget that? Uh,
late great. Patrice O'neil, the, I
think this is the fourth one we've done.
MMM.
Yeah. 13, 14, 15, 16. Yeah, this is
the fourth one. So I already flying by.
Um, it's sold out. There will be
a few tickets released at the,
um,
right before the show starts is always
a few people that requested tickets and
then they don't show up.
So there's a chance if you walk
up there might be a sub tickets.
It's going to be an amazing
lineup and as always, uh,
other than the money that we use
to a pay to rent out the theater,
all monies goes to a,
Patrice has loved ones and it's really
made an unbelievably positive effect on
their lives.
You know,
his mom has been able to get a condo and
his stepdaughters is going to private
school since the benefit.
And um,
just the quality of their lives
basically stayed the same, you know,
Patrice was taken care of
them. So, um, it's really,
it's the greatest thing that I'm involved
in during the course of the year and
I'm so happy that you guys step
it up every year and buy tickets.
So I want to thank everybody who
bought it means the world to me.
And everybody involved and all the comics
that take time out of their schedule
to come down there and um,
and perform.
And it's just a,
it's just an awesome thing and we're just
going to keep doing it as long as you
guys keep showing up. All right. So thank
you. Thank you for that. And with that,
let's get into some of the reeds here
for their, uh, for this week. All right.
What are we up to here at 33 minutes?
All, all right. All right. Hacky hate.
Hey Bill. How I, yeah, he
says, I am not a patriots fan.
I am a die hard bears fan.
After the Patriots lost,
all I sell on Facebook was people
trashing Brady and bringing up Trump and
deflate gate.
I get it there on most.
They're on top most of the time and
people love to trash him or whoever's
winning at life.
Now let's stop giving excuses to these
pansy ass fucking sports fan who spent
sports fans spend 90% of their
fucking time talking about gossip.
It all gets classified under gossip.
Every hack who was,
who was the static that the
pastry is loss is an asshole.
Especially the ones who will declare they
could care less about sports. Congrats.
You're about as cool as the
guy who paints his face.
The only time I'd talk shit about the
Patriots is to remind them of 1985 even.
That's pretty weak. Go bears. Um,
yeah, but you know, if you're on top,
you got to expect that people
are going to give you shit. Um,
the only thing I didn't like was, was when
the, the Broncos' defense, you know, oh,
we're getting sugar here. What
about Tom Brady? It's like,
well then when a fucking Superbowl win
four of them and they'll talk about you.
The Patriots never talked
shit about the Broncos.
They never said that they
were better than the Broncos.
And I also love to where it's just so
like, you know, they were favorites,
they were fit, but like the Patriots
made themselves favorites that, you know,
what's really overrated is,
is being a favorite or being an underdog
has nothing to do with your team.
It has to do with the fucking dope.
In the buffalo wild wings who's
betting on games? All right.
What Vegas tries to do is they try to
get money on both sides of the ball,
so they try to pick a number.
All right,
that's going to entice people to go 50 50.
That's why the line changes
during the course of the week.
Did one team get better or another
team get get worse? I mean,
if there's an injury, yes, but
generally speaking, no, what happens is,
is this too much money going to one side?
So they need to entice people to
come back the other side. Because if,
if you know that you can't have like 90%
of the money on one side of the ball,
that could completely fuck
over the gambling ring or the,
uh, they don't like those
odds and because ties lose,
that's enough to tip it in their fucking
favor. That's basically what goes on,
which is why,
you know,
if you look back in oh seven when the
Patriots beat the giants the last game of
the year and the giants put up like
fucking 33 or 34 points and we only won by
like three or something.
That's why like a month later we
were still 14 point favorites.
It hasn't, all the Patriots are
overhyped. They weren't over hyped.
What happened was the Superbowl brings
out people who don't know shit about
football.
Okay?
All right. It brings out the fucking
ladies. It brings out all, you know,
there's nothing worse than a super bowl
party if you give a shit about football,
if you really like the super belief,
really like football.
If you're really a football fan,
you watch it alone or you watch it with
like two or three other people that keep
their fucking mouth shut, right? Um,
but what happens is during the Superbowl
that brings out all the fucking,
the novice fans that people don't even
watch and all they see is 18 and all the
fucking door. Or they know
Brady. Like they know,
they know Tom Brady the way I
know Darth Vader. All right.
I can't tell you a fucking thing
about the last,
like I don't even know how many,
there's Ben since the original three.
I know Veda is fucking Luke's
father and that fucking uh,
okay.
Luke in layer are brother and sister and
that they kind of had like this sexual
tension in wanting to fuck
each other in the beginning,
which I think is a really weird thing
to put into a kid's movie, don't you?
Um,
okay.
Maybe he didn't know that
when he initially wrote it
and then he just needed a
good left turn when he was writing the
second one. I have no fucking idea,
but I think the way he tried to make it
up was with those journals and the third
one, you know, what are the
fuck they did, you know,
I know what the fuck they did. So
anyways, so that's as much as I can.
As much as I know about star wars,
these people know about football.
So then they come in and they go to Vegas
and everybody goes in and thinks that
they're fucking Sean Connery and James
Bond. Right. They were, you know,
they fucking go down there and
they got some Almond Vegas suit on.
Their wife's wearing some fucking,
you know,
sparkly number and everybody's out there,
stepping outside of themselves in and say,
I want to gamble.
I want to get in the action.
Who's playing? I don't know
who that other team is.
I know Tom Brady is, let me, yeah, let
me put a hundred bucks on his stone.
The clef of his fucking Chin.
And that's how the line goes from
what it should be about three,
four points to all the way up to 14.
That's what the fuck happens. All right.
And that was for everybody who doesn't
fucking gamble. Okay. All right,
cool enough already. We get it.
Your team lost and you're fucking,
you're in a country mood. Um, thank
God that guy fell out of his stance.
He didn't even look that drunk.
I just loved his fucking gap jeans
just fucking straight up in the air.
All right. Next question
here. Um, oh, by the way,
if you'd like to donate to this podcast,
um,
all you gotta do is just go to
a next time you go to Amazon.
If the next time I'm going
to buy something on that,
uh, just go to my website,
billboard.com, click on the podcast page
and then you just click on the Amazon.
It just takes you there. It doesn't cost
you any extra money. You might, you know,
later on in life, if your index finger
wears out, you might think like,
you know what, if I didn't do those
extra two clicks with my index finger,
maybe I would have had another 10 minutes
of joy and no fucking constant pain
and my index finger. Other than that,
there's really nothing I even do it.
I even go when I go to Amazon. Well, why
wouldn't I guess I get the money right?
You don't. I did. I went on there
and I fixed my fucking cool.
I Dunno what the fuck happened to my
cooler this year that the rose bowl,
it's been to every Rosebowl that I've
been to and I've been to eight of them at
this point and I never had
a fucking problem. And at
some point, like my cooler,
basically it opens up to a point,
you know,
the hinges stop it from opening and
then there's this strap to keep it from
going any further. And I
don't know what happened. Um,
cause I fucking passed out like at
like 10 o'clock in the morning, so,
okay.
And I didn't even notice
that my cooler was fucked up.
But at the end of the night when
I got my cooler back, the, uh,
it had basically been decapitated.
The strap was busted and the hinges were
busted. And I was like, what the fuck?
What happened? You know, it's like the
hulk opened the thing up or something.
She just like, just open a little, it's
fine. But then I was thinking of Warren,
I fell down was I was drunk that I
land on the cooler and it's like, no,
I w I wouldn't noticed that. I landed flat
on my, I landed like that fucking guy.
What? He fell out of the stands.
It's how I fell. I fell on the grass.
Do you realize I was on a fairway,
a straight fairway golf course and
I lost my balance and fell down.
That's how fucking drunk I was. And you
know what? It was fucking great. Um,
so anyways, I went to a, Oh
actually I didn't go to Amazon,
I just looked up Igloo.
Um,
okay.
Cooler repair kit and they got like,
there's two different kinds of hinges and
I accidentally ordered two of them and
I only need one of them.
So I have an extra repair kit and I
know you know the odds and they send you
like three sets of hinges. You
know, if you have like the,
the giant one,
you know,
the person who kills his wife and
doesn't want anybody to know and just say
she's on vacation and he cuts her up.
Like they have that size hinge for that
cooler. And then they just got, you know,
the happy drunks that falls down
on New Year's Day, you know,
so they come with three
sets of hinges for each.
So I have an entire extra one.
So anybody out there who has like a,
a cooler that needs to be replaced,
they had, comes with everything.
Even like the drain little drain hole,
fucking spout thing, it's got that, um,
the strap does come separately.
I don't have an extra strap,
but I have an extra or a repair kits.
So if anybody wants it,
send us an email with an address and
I'll send it out to you because what else
am I gonna do with it? I'm not going to
throw it out. And some day if I ever move,
um, you know, I've got to pack up
something that I don't even fucking neat.
So there you go. Oh, by the way, uh, yeah,
I'm still in the running here to maybe
get this drum room made slash podcast
room in the back of my garage.
Um, as always, there's major,
major fucking structural issues. But, um,
I don't know. It's just I got up, I
got to shore up that part of the house.
But there's,
there's all these,
these all these fucking issues that I
can't even talk about because, you know,
I'm getting a permit. I'm doing all of
that fucking shit. I know somebody like,
well, you don't need a
full can permit. It is flu.
If you're building within the structure,
if you know what Eric and the square
footage you, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But I know all that shit.
But like, I just, you know,
anytime you start hammering you and
your fucking garage enablers here at the
fucking rat you out,
I just don't need the fucking headache.
So I am doing my due diligence
and it's taking a long time.
But, um, I'm gonna, I'm gonna make this,
I'm going to make this fucking happen
and I have a 71 Ludwig green sparkled all
bottom size drums and I'm going to make
sure that they fucking fit in there.
And I'm going to fucking, I don't
give a shit. What do I care? Right?
You know,
the oceans are all fished out.
The government takes all your fucking
money. You know, I don't give a fuck.
I'm going all out with
distinct this thing.
I'm literally going to be able to pull,
I'm going to tell this guy,
if I'm able to do this and I'm not going
to have a fucking problem legally and I
could build the fucking
thing I want to build.
I'm literally going to be able to play
at two o'clock in the fucking morning and
no one's even going to hear it.
They might,
it might sound like a
stereos on really low. Um,
but I'd never be a Douche enough
to play then, um, at least sober.
That'd be great. Then write,
anytime I'm bugging my wife,
I can just walk out the back door,
go into my garage,
sit down and put on a Zeppelin album,
guns and roses.
Fucking uh, all my fucking Shit I
listened to when I was growing up.
Yeah.
Queens of the Stone Age,
you know?
Okay.
At what, what else do you fucking need
though? You know what else I need?
I need a bar up there.
Right. Flatscreen TV.
He was funny about a man cave.
When somebody really goes throws
down and they're fucking man cave.
All I hear is I am not happily married
and we should doing is you're building a
mini version of what your life would
look like if you weren't what your house
would look like if you weren't married.
Like after you show them the house
with all the throw pillows and all the
fucking popery and all that shit,
you bring your buddy out to the
garage and you just like, yeah,
if I wasn't married,
like this is what it would look like.
But you know what's funny about that?
I'm old enough to know that if
your house did look like that,
the ice,
I see the loneliness in it because
the bottom line is a man cave.
What it is is like, what's your
building is what you wish you had,
you wish you could afford when
you were fucking 22 years old.
That's basically it. And the problem
is, is if you do it, honestly,
if you're actually work your balls off,
you know,
and you don't steal from anybody
or anything, that fucking shit,
it's going to take it to you about 50,
unless you one of these fucking nerds
in silicone valley that comes up with an
APP or some shit, you know,
you really don't get paid.
So you get close to 50. That's
just how it is. You know?
It's just how it is. Except for Cam
Newton. He's getting paid around, right?
Oh my God. No. He's having
more fun than that guy.
If you look up fun in the dictionary,
um,
anyways, I, um, yeah,
I'm going to fucking make a
little podcast thing. I mean,
I don't have a lot of
room, but, uh, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna fucking do it
upright. And, uh, you know,
getting back and taking lessons again
through the shit that I'm actually paying
attention to now that I never paid
attention to how I hold onto the sticks,
where I'm hitting the snare drum,
my balance,
all of that shit used to be
all about going on youtube,
seeing some guy do one of those
Gospel Chop fucking licks.
And then I'm going to go down here and
fucking just do this for fucking nine
days in a row and then I'll be able
to do that, you know, pull this,
fill off next time I walk
into Guitar Center. And, uh,
and then meanwhile all my
other planks shocked. And uh,
I've just had this
total epiphany about all
of it. And, uh, it's funny,
I'm not doing nearly as
much as I used to do,
but I think I'm playing better
than I ever played in a, I dunno.
It's fucking exciting. It gives me a
reason to get up in the morning, you know?
So anyways,
let's move on to the next question here.
Uh,
oh my God.
Did I tell you guys how I butchered that
fucking porkchop meal that I made? Oh,
still sick over that. Oh, I'm like,
I'm eating pork chops again this week
cause I have to redeem myself. All right,
so the hacky hate thing.
Yeah,
that just kind of comes with winning
games or whatever. I'm all right.
No Asian diversity at the Oscars.
Bill hello from Canada.
Would love to hear what your take is on
why no one's complaining about the lack
of agents at the Oscars.
Oh you motherfucker. That's
the bit I was going to do.
That was the bit I was going to do. Yeah,
that's it's as he goes, as an Asian,
I don't care because a,
I suspect we are producing good
enough shit not to not, oh wait,
we're not producing good enough shit.
Not because we're Asian be Asians aren't
getting sweet rolls because I'm not
profitable.
They aren't going to cast an Asian
parentheses or black or female actor that
would make more money out
of some white conspiracy.
Yeah,
dude, he had like fucking two
sets of parenthesis in there.
Asians aren't getting sweet rolls
because it's not profitable.
They aren't going there.
They aren't going to not cast an Asian
yeah.
Or black or female actor that, well,
I see what you're saying. They're not,
they aren't going to not cast an Asian
actor that would make more money out of
some white conspiracy. So you're saying
if they, if they would make them money,
then they would see who cares if they
don't like how the Oscars define the best,
whatever.
I don't get why.
And then that's the end of it. I
see what you're saying. Well, yeah,
you're looking at it from a very,
uh,
like money. Like I think that's a
lot of times sometimes, you know,
it looks like it's racism. A lot
of times it's just money. But what,
yeah,
I think
American cinema is finally realizing
is that there's a whole bunch of other
people in the world that they can actually
get money from if they gave a fuck to
make a movie that would appeal to them.
And the only thing,
reason why I think they're doing that
is because everybody's stole movies and
it's so hard to make
money off of them now.
And there's such a big
fucking risk because what
happened to the music business
has happened slash is happening
to the movie business right now,
which is why there's really no more
like from like $20 million to like $70
million. They don't make movies in
that budget anymore. They just don't.
It's either like some fucking $100 million
star wars action hero movie or it's
like fucking below $10 million it seems,
um,
all the way down to like a hundred
grand, like indie sort of, you know,
micro budget fucking thing.
Um,
so yeah, I see what you're saying. Yeah. I
mean, yeah, there's no agents area there.
Where's the outcry for
that? Well, people don't,
people give a fuck about themselves.
That's the one thing that I can
say about people in general,
straight across the board,
you know,
which is why I guess white people need,
because they're running shit, quote,
running shit. You know what I mean?
Like they're all cooperating with one
another because there's white people in
those positions.
They need to take the time to actually
give a fuck about other stuff.
Cause I gotta be honest with you.
I've thought that kid that played
easy and a straight Outta Compton,
he should've gotten nominated. He was,
he was the fucking Shit and that movie,
I should know that actor's name.
He was, you know what? God dammit.
Why don't I step outside my whiteness?
I'm going to set the example here
right now and I'll tell you right now,
there's nobody having more fun
right now going on the Internet.
Then this guy, you look up fun on the
Internet. There'll be a picture of me,
easy e actor,
uh,
Eric Lynn, right is here.
Jason Mitchell on playing e.
That fucking guy was that.
He should have got something
to even get a golden globe.
You get nominated for that.
Um,
that was one of those movies that
I actually didn't even want to see.
There was some line that
what's his face, uh, um,
Giamatti said, you know what I mean?
You can't try it out like that 40,
yelled, whatever the fuck he
yells. I go, Jesus Christ, this,
this looks really heavy handed.
You know what I mean?
And then they always have
to have the, uh, you know,
they always have to have the white,
white angel and those movies
when they show racism,
so then white people will go so they
can lie to themselves and be like, yeah,
if I was there, that's the white guy.
I would be, I'd be the Angel White Guy.
I wouldn't be the, the uh, you
know, the racist sketch. Um,
yeah, no, it's a very, it's
a very interesting, the whole
fucking thing is, is really
interesting. I Dunno, I have no idea.
I mean, I think you shouldn't just say,
look,
black actors should be nominated.
You should fucking then back it up.
You know what I mean?
And give shout outs to
people that fucking deserve.
It used to be like Jason Mitchell
playing easy and straight outta Compton.
I would have fuck is going to say
he shouldn't have got something. Um,
or maybe they did do that. I
gotta be honest with you. I don't,
I don't really pay attention to award
shows. I fucking can't stand up.
Um, the horrific,
they're fucking horrific.
They're boring as hell. There's usually
one moment that's worth fucking watching.
And at that with the Internet,
you're not going to miss it.
They're just going to show it to you.
So why would you waste four hours
of your life watching the shit?
Like for the Golden Globes, the, the,
the moment of the night was Jim Carrey.
Jim Carrey stole that.
He met fucking speech was hilarious.
And for what I've heard,
um, from people out here,
he just winged that thing. That's
how fucking funny that guy is. Um,
and watching him do that and the brutal
honesty of it really made me wish I
could still watch them do stand up
to be honest with you. Um, all right,
here we go to your health.
Good serve bill.
I've heard you discussed many topics with,
with yourself on the podcast about
health and longevity of the major topics.
I,
he food and exercise.
I would have to suggest considering
another area to focus on breathing.
Yeah. Jesus. I got to work
on this to breathing is huge.
How you breathe and the types of breaths
you take during the day to really
change your body for the better.
I just literally thought about
breathing and got more relaxed.
This is this yoga shit that I try to slow
my brain down for. Conscious breathing,
conscious breathing. Oh, you're going
to plug your book in the middle of this.
You motherfucker. You know what?
You got me. He suckered me in,
but I'm going to read it like deep
thoughts by Jack Handy. Here we go.
Conscious breathing is a book
and a great place to start.
Also,
a man by the name of Wim Hoff is doing
amazing things and has been on Joe
Rogan's podcast. You may not
have three hours to listen to it,
but if you run into,
I'm sure he can give you the breakdown.
Thanks for the free laughs.
MMM,
no, I'll listen to anybody that's on
Rogan's podcast. Joe Rogan's podcast,
the fastest fucking three hours you're
ever going to spend a very ever lucky
enough to be a fucking guest.
You can be like at been here like 40
minutes and then all of a sudden you're
like, how the fuck is it like seven
o'clock at night? I missed, uh,
I missed my meal. Um, well I'll, I'll
give it a chance. I'll give it a try.
I know I definitely need to
fucking stress less and uh,
that's always like one of my goals.
I haven't been drinking this year though.
The day after the Rose Bowl
was the last time I, I boost.
MMM.
I had one gulp of wine after I made this
really rich dinner and in my stomach I
needed to settle it.
So my wife was drinking some wine.
I just took a gulp of that.
And then the last three nights in a row,
I'm getting rid of these Rosebowl beers.
I just drink like one light beer.
I just have one and then, then, then I'm
done. And he just kind of makes me sleepy,
but I'm just trying to free up some room
in the fridge because every year at the
end of the Rose Bowl,
I get stuck with all the extra beers
and like fucking 15 cans of half used
mustard.
Um,
I can't all the condiments and a broken
cooler. All right. Trash in the ocean.
Hey Bill, I know you talk about
this all the time on your podcast,
but believe it or not, there are
people who do not believe our trash,
uh,
dumped in the ocean is a problem. Well,
there's always gonna be those people.
There's also people who thought
the fucking world was flat. Well,
I guess I would have thought the
world is flat. If I lived back then,
people didn't think that we were f we
are earning an effect on the climate.
Okay.
You know, all the fucking trees
that we've cut down that alone.
You know what I mean? It's
um, all right. Anyways,
he says there was another
scientific study done.
If you believe in that
kind of thing that states,
plastics will outweigh
fish in the ocean by 2050.
I saw that.
I don't think that that's going to happen
because I have a feeling that mother
nature has had enough with us and will,
you know,
when they keep predicting by 2090,
the population will more than
fucking Quinn. Topal I think that,
you know, we're already long passed the
tipping point. Scientists have said,
we're past the point where we can
even fix this fucking thing. So I,
this is like when you can't do your
homework at some point you're like Ma,
and she comes down and helps you out.
I think Mother Nature is going to do that.
And uh, she's an old school mom and
she's going to slap the shit out of us.
Uh,
but you don't need to listen to me say
this. Just listen to George Carlin.
He'll tell you all about
it. I'm all right. He said,
I guess these assholes assume there'll
be dead by then and don't give a shit.
Long time listening to hear,
just saw you in Indy back in October.
I can share you. We aren't all ignorant,
KKK asshole or Jim or say fancy. And I,
you know, I just say that just
to fuck with you. Jesus Christ.
I grew up outside of Boston.
Half the people in the Klan would go
there and be like, all right, hey,
take it easy. You know, I understand,
but easy. All right, thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Okay.
And then they sent me the, uh,
the unbelievably depressing link,
which I don't,
I don't even go to him anymore.
I don't even go to them anymore because
all they do is depress me. All right?
Average amount of waste produced
by humans. Jesus Christ.
We're just staring into this.
Hey Bill,
I'm from Columbia and love your
podcast and you stand up comedy. Hey,
that's fucking great.
Oh, you're from Columbia.
I thought you were down there listening.
Uh, brought over. You're from there,
right? You live there. At some point,
you're still listening to the podcast.
It's still cool. Uh, he
goes, um, the are, she goes,
I don't know who the fuck wrote this.
He goes the other day I was wondering
how much poop is produced by humans on a
daily basis. And I did a little research
on the Internet and some calculations,
which I would like to share with
you and your audience. Okay?
According to the world fact book,
the world population consists
okay,
of 7 billion,
174,611
okay,
wait a minute. Why not?
Well, it's 7 billion.
174,611,584 people,
and the average human being
weighs around 62 kilograms. Oh,
you motherfucker. I want to know what
that is in pounds. I Wagga, I gotta.
I gotta switch that over.
I want to see where the fuck I'm at.
Okay.
Wait, what did you just say?
62 what do you guys think?
The average person who, I would say the
average person weighs about a hundred.
A lot of starving people.
I'll go 162 pounds. What is,
what do you say here? All right. 62
and
L. B S. Right.
Okay.
That's equal to 136 pounds.
Holy Shit.
God Damn it. There's a lot of small
or starving people in the world.
All right. Now the average,
that means I am right now,
I'm like 40 pounds over the average and
the average human being. All right. Now,
the daily average for
stool gross is one ounce,
okay?
Per 12 pounds of body weight,
which means the average
person pope's 11.39 ounces.
Therefore,
each day the planet receives
2,295,876 metric tons of shit,
but since the average stool is
75% water through, this is gross,
it will be safe to say they humans
produce 1,000,007 or 21,000 hundred seven
metric tons of poop every day.
Jesus Christ,
you really taken all the fun out of
this podcast to put this in perspective.
I think you put it into perspective,
but he's going to keep going with the
empire state building weighs 350,000 tons,
so human beings pupae the equivalent of
five giant turds the size of the empire
state building.
If we add farts to the equation,
this fucking dude is all in,
okay?
The average person fart 17 times a day.
That's it.
Try eating a salad.
Fucking double your numbers.
You Break Dan Marino's
record times 17 times a day,
producing a litter, a leader
of Fart in total, a litter,
l. I. T. T. E. R. That's
a litter of Fart in total,
which gives a new meaning
to a breathing fresh air.
Okay?
I've included the links
where I got the information.
Okay?
At the end of this email,
and when you think about it,
on top of eating our own rollerblades,
we're eating our own shit. By the way,
everything you read or hear
about Columbia is true,
that go have a meaningful experience
with yourself. Does that mean go, oh,
that means go fuck yourself. Ah,
this guy's a clubber son of a bitch.
Um, Jesus Christ. Well,
you know what? Hey,
how about I am the podcast with
what I promised to do last week,
which is I was going to start reading
segments from the Bible. The granted,
I don't own a Bible.
All right,
let's start with John Three
16 because I'm a sports fan.
John three 60 he said it onto you with,
all right,
John Three 16.
For God so loved the world that he
gave his only his one and only son,
that whoever believes in him
shall not perish. I perish,
but have eternal life. Well, that's
straight forward. He led his kid die.
So as long as you believe that
that happened, you will not die.
You will have eternal life.
You will live forever.
Think about that forever.
You know you have, it's been at the DMV.
Just imagine that, except it never ends,
right.
Okay.
What the fuck would you do forever?
There's no way that that's fucking true.
Okay?
You know,
movies don't go on forever.
Planets don't go on forever or livable.
Planets don't go on forever.
I'll fuck. This is why I don't
read the Bible and I saw,
I don't fucking get all right,
let's, let's, let's, uh,
let's just look up Bible
passages. Bib. Ellie,
it'd be funny if this actually
got me back to going to church.
I still loved going church. You know what
I mean? I still like going, you know,
Katie Ban my dad, JJ, Jay's grise.
There's dive for Ross and his resilience.
Mm.
From the dead. All right. Encouraging
Bible Verses Hope Bible Verses
Bible Verses Bite friendships.
Bible verses.
Let's give hope. Encouraging.
Well, where the fuck is it?
Yeah.
Ah, I just wanted to open it
like the phone book the Bible.
I'm gonna look up the Bible.
Please read the Bible.
Okay.
Www. A Free Bible on your
phone. I don't want it.
I want it on my fucking scream. I
want amber. No. What? Cheeseburger.
Visual Kim.
James Bible.
Commit thy way unto the Lord.
Trust also in him and he
shall bring it to pass.
Okay.
Bring what? Commit Day. Way unto the Lord.
All right, so walk in the general
direction of the Lord. Trust also in him,
while if I'm walking towards him, aren't,
isn't that trusting him? Winning up,
creeping up on him. Hey Man, just
making sure everything's cool.
I'm walking your way,
but you know,
just wave your white flag.
Okay.
Don't open a trap door
when I get there dude.
And he shall bring it to pass.
Genesis.
I remember reading this.
It like makes sense for like
three fucking sentences.
And then you just like what?
In the beginning,
God created the heaven and the earth and
the earth was without form and void and
darkness was upon the
face of the deep period,
the deep what and the spirit of God
moved upon. That's like when they go,
you know,
they got to eat up some clock.
Okay?
Darkness was upon the face of the deep
and the spirit of God moved upon the face
of the waters.
I thought there wasn't any
that there wasn't any water,
there wasn't anything.
How was it water for his
face to be on and God said,
let there be light and there was light.
Let there be sad.
There was sound. Is this
Bon Scott? God said,
let there be light and there was like,
well, what was he doing before that?
He was just sitting in the
darkness all by himself.
Just one day he's laying there going,
I'm going to make some shit,
and God saw the light that it was good
and God divided the light from the
darkness. God called the light
day. It's like Cam Newton.
Everything's about the same guy.
I'll tell you right now,
nobody's having more fun
than God making Earth.
He's like a kid in a candy store that
doesn't exist and kids don't exist cause
he hadn't made it yet.
Ah, fuck this. Genesis.
Let's look at job.
See what old job had to say.
What the fuck is he? Well, let's read
Titus. That's the name of a comic I know.
How about that? All right. Paul,
a servant of God and an
apostle of Jesus Christ
according to the faith of God's elect
and the acknowledging of the truth,
which is after godliness.
I feel like somebody is
trying to sell me a car.
That was all one sentence
in hope of eternal life,
which God that cannot lie
promised before the world began.
Okay
Dude, this is like the the like
God called everything you know,
before you even born and all that,
but half and do times manifested
his words. You know what?
I thought this would be a funny bit.
This is just fucking annoying,
but half to do times manifested
his word through preaching,
which was committed unto me according
to the commandment of God, our savior.
It's just, it just goes in circles to
Titus. My own son, after the common faith,
he had another kid had
Jesus and he had Titus.
Okay.
Grace,
mercy and peace.
Yeah.
Who are they as grace? Grace.
Was she another virgin?
How many times is it going to use
this verge and thinks he banged them
right.
He had Jesus with Mary and then grace
was this fucking side piece and he had
Titus.
All right.
Okay.
For this cause left ID and Crete that
thou should have set in order the things
that are wanting and orders elders
in every city as I appointed thee,
if any, be blameless. The husband of
one wife having faithful children,
not accused of riot or unruly.
It's not a sentence or maybe
it was back then, you know,
if I get judged Sunday, you know, and,
and God stand in that and being like,
I just feel like to, you
know, I tried to get through,
I tried to get through the book.
I don't know what to tell you.
Okay.
As far as I can see,
it's a bunch of fragments.
All right.
They're not complete thoughts.
You know, you can't, right.
Just because you put a period at the
end of it doesn't make it a sentence.
Right.
All right. This is a podcast
for this week. Once again,
congratulations to the Broncos.
Congratulations.
Still The lady who got a job,
I'm going to end this positive.
Gradually says to the lady who got
the job there at the buffalo bills.
I'm sure you're going to do a great job.
I'm just a grumpy old fucking matters.
His team lost. All right.
Congratulations to the panthers. Um,
I look forward to seeing Cam Newton.
Okay.
You know, play against Peyton
manning. It's going to be great.
I love that he called them the
sheriff. Um, I thought that was cool.
You know, the best of the old versus the
best of the new. So I'm an old fucker,
so I'm going to have to route.
I got a group for the Denver Broncos,
they AAFC and Peyton
manning. Um, even though I,
the panthers and I love the way they
fucking playing that defense is to shit.
And um, I dunno. I just hope it's
a good game. I hope the panthers,
if they're going to win or the Broncos,
I just don't want anybody beating
the fuck out of anybody. Right.
But I will tell you as always, I
will be watching it by myself. Okay?
I'm not going to, I might go to a
Superbowl party cause my team's out it,
but I don't think so.
I want to see Peyton's last game and
I hope it goes out like La and a,
I'm going to do what I always do. All
right, I'm going to tape the game.
You let it go for a good 90 minutes.
As I mentioned,
you shut your phone off. You get the
grill going, you crack a couple of beers.
You know,
you make yourself a burger to you.
Invite a couple of friends over
and then he got, all right,
let's sit down and watch it. And you
blow through all the fucking beginning.
Oh,
brave, right bombed kickoff. There we go.
Blow through all the fucking commercials.
Fast forward through Beyonce
lip sinking during halftime.
You get caught up halfway through
the third fucking quarter. And, uh,
and if there were any cool commercials
that you missed, you have them recorded,
but someone's going to put
them up online anyways.
You're not going to miss a fucking thing.
And you can watch the Superbowl and about,
I dunno, you can watch in about two,
two hours and 20 minutes, two hours, two
and a half hours. It's fucking tremendous.
All right. God bless you
guys yet, go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check in on Thursday.
All right.